- Next up is Mihovail talking
about New Years' Resolutions.
So, that's timely here.
He's said he's trying to
change his approach this year
to focus on not making
a list of resolutions,
but making a list of
mistakes and explanations
to look at why he didn't follow through
on making those plans
and fixing the mistakes from last year.
What are our thoughts
and how do you go about
making resolutions, or even
do you for the new year?
- For the New Year, I'm
going to try one thing, Evan,
because I'm so conscious.
I bust my own chops, I'll be honest.
I demand a lot from myself.
I never think when I look at
myself I've done well enough,
and that's kind of deep
lingering in my psyche.
I think, and this is advice
I'd give to everybody,
when you look at yourselves,
we've got great people today
joined us for the blab,
I think I'm going to try
in the New Year to say,
not for me but for other people,
just look for the good things they did,
and it's almost back to sports.
If you're competing against
kind of, I don't know,
say, Usain Bolt, for the 100 Meters,
do you beat yourself up all the time
on that 1/100th of a second
where you don't come out the blocks?
Or do you celebrate the
things that you do well
in the last 50 meters where you accelerate
away from everybody else?
I think we should, as
leaders, focus way more
on the things we do well,
and make them even better,
and if we do that, I think we'll
find we make less mistakes,
and also, any sort of
improvements we need,
you can call them
whatever you want really.
We've all got weaknesses.
But, if you accentuate the positives,
and if you've got people working
for you in your businesses,
if you just give them
a bit of praise about
what efforts they've put
in to achieving something
that was connected to your big
passion, and dream, and idea,
then, wow.
You'll make them rise 40,000ft,
and fly out of your home office,
and they'll be able to rule the world.
And I think so often when I look,
and I say this for myself in
terms of one learning for me,
it's so easy to say,
"Oh you did this. Okay,
"but I want to tell you
about these three things
"that you didn't do so good."
And the voice in your head,
because a lot of overcoming the fear
is smashing down the walls,
and smashing those voices that
tell you you can't do stuff
because you know you can.
You know you can, and
if you keep on listening
to the voices around you or in your head,
they'll just grind you down,
and you kind of just
lose the will to live.
So, I do think, actually,
both for yourself,
it's really good to
celebrate the positive,
to savor the moment, but most of all,
if you're a company of
two, three, five people,
wouldn't it be powerful
when you've won a big order
to take everybody out for dinner,
and just celebrate that and enjoy it,
and say "Your contribution was this,
"and if we hadn't won that."
It maybe be a pitch or it maybe
the product they invented,
or whatever.
It's so powerful to
galvanize the people together
against your passion for your dream.
So, one thing I do is in terms
of the New Years Resolution,
yeah, okay, spend maybe 20%
of your time when you do that
on the one mistake, but
actually spend 80% of the time
on the things you did really, really well,
and then you become a
super trained athlete
to do them over better, and, you know,
focus on the positive.
- To Steven's point, I would encourage you
to not just wait 'til
the New Years' Resolution
to come around to start doing it.
If Steven inspired you with
that story about celebrating
the win, then today is the resolution.
Like, do it right now.
So many people wait until the
New Year to start something,
and then they fall off
track a couple weeks in.
I would love for you guys
listening and watching,
for entrepreneurs, to when you get an idea
just go out and try it.
Even if you don't know
all the details, right?
So, I want to celebrate a win.
Okay, great.
Is it going to be a restaurant?
Is it going to be with a gift certificate?
You start planning all the things out,
the perfectionists in us,
planning all the things out.
You make it some big thing,
and then because it's
so big we never do it.
Because it has to be the perfect thing,
and we never do anything.
And I think just starting something small,
it could be a phone call, it
could be taking somebody out,
it could be just buying
them a Starbucks, whatever,
just try something.
See how it feels, and adjust.
And I would love for you
guys to get in the habit
of constantly doing the self evaluation
and checking yourself,
and not waiting until
New Years' or your birthday,
or some other arbitrary day.
Like, just start doing it.
You get inspired by something
you hear today, take action!
That would make both Steven
and myself insanely happy.
That's the goal, right?
Don't wait another,
you know, couple weeks.
Do something today.
- Yeah, I think, Evan, as well,
that's such a great point.
And, you know, another great quote,
"Never leave til tomorrow
what can be done today."
And, I think, you know,
why wait til the New Year?
This is a great holiday season,
and for you guys who've
got customers out there,
and if you got people working for you,
colleagues that work for
you and follow your dream,
what a golden time to say a
really heartfelt thank you
in the holiday season.
It's sort of a time to pause, reflect.
They're going to go home with
their families, or friends,
and it's a really a pretty cool time
to pick up the phone to customers,
send them a SMS or a direct message,
just saying "Thank you so much
"for your custom over this year.
"I'm really excited about
working with you again in 2017."
So, this is a great time,
not just the new year,
but the end of the year, just to celebrate
what you've achieved this year,
recognize a few other people,
especially your customers,
and the people who've built that,
which is the people you employ.
Just say thank you very much.
It's a good time,
and I think everybody
wants to feel valued,
and the more you do that, again,
it's kind of weird, there's
this flywheel of positivity
because if you say that to your colleagues
and you say that to your customer
they're feeling the love your big idea,
and they'll give you great feedback.